[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
happy nfl sunday everybody you just
tapped into the br betting squad ride
live in the bleacher report app
presented by draftkings i'm connor
rogers alongside the legendary greg
ivory great christmas is right around
the corner man heard some rumors you're
in the giving spirit yet again
connor i got the green on it's not red
but it's green christmas is red and
green
so i got the green on and you know what
that means i'm in the comments right now
giving away hoodies uh i'm looking for
takes looking for takes and i see uh
i see i see
br
no actually jake jake s
t o n j s j-s-t-o-n
says tom brady for mvp
tom brady for mvp shout out to you you
are walking away with a hoodie and we're
going to get into that a little bit
later but for now hopefully you all rove
with us last week because the squad ride
cashed yet again it's been a banner year
trail follow along make some money let's
have some fun you know the drill by now
this is the show where we're looking for
locks to get in the end zone we ask you
every week on social in the app who is
scoring a touchdown today
here's the top picks you sent us for the
weekend slate tyree kale at the top
right there with corduro patterson
devonte adams heavy wide receiver board
today and one former wide receiver now
running back in patterson javonte adams
and cd lam julio jones may be finally
healthy jamar chase hollywood
brown and then tom brady rushing plus
650 brady we're feeling crazy today tom
brady
oh man his mvp odds are way way better
than that so i'm excited to get into
this but before we do that let's take a
look at some of our favorite lock legend
videos uh that were not featured from
last week
what's up bleacher report we are back
here with atlas and today i'm gonna be
pulling madden packs to determine who
i'm gonna pick this week for score
touchdown it's my decision day on who's
gonna score it anytime touchdown in week
13. pick a hat any hat you ready atlas
this week we're hammering try this
kelsey okay then now
atlas picked the red ball today we're
gonna go with miles casper justin
jefferson anytime touchdown baby let's
go
greg let him know what we're giving away
today
connor i'm not only giving out hoodies
i'm also giving away two not one but two
nfl jerseys one goes to the winning lock
legend and one goes to a lucky commenter
like you so don't go nowhere stay tuned
in to the end of the show because that's
what i'm gonna give it out get in the
comments
you guys want a jersey you guys want a
hoodie i need gifts i need emojis but
most importantly type this out with me i
need winners
only please conor
winners only please let's do it we have
four legendary picks to show you you
know the deal the last one standing is
our squad ride leader those odds are
gonna go somewhere a little bit upward
let's get it going
first pick of the day comes from h
bowersock tell us who's scoring a
touchdown today
quick before they find me what year is
it
2021 came in just in time
what i've stolen from vegas is the lock
of the century and it is happening this
very weekend with all the money you have
ryan tannehill anytime touchdown he's
playing the garbage jaguars with all the
money you have ryan tannehill anytime
touchdown
fbi open up they found me
good luck
the time travel legend i am nervous for
him not just because of that anxiety but
the fact that he picked ryan tannehill
plus 310 seems like a bold decision here
to kick things off greg before we get
into that discussion let's see who's he
who he's up against decision time second
pitch comes from numero 25 the goat
let's see the choice
first off i want to give a shout out to
the br ben page on instagram for the
parlay tomorrow for any time scorers
being that i am from dallas i gotta rock
with my boy
[Music]
let's get it
cowboys nation baby
the cowboys could use my man in the
trenches i like his energy you've heard
our first two pitches
greg we got the time travel legend and i
believe it if ryan tannehill does score
we got cd lamb from the cowboy legend
how are we feeling about these things to
kick off this week's show
connor
uh
the ryan tannehill pick i don't even
know where to start
he's flabbergasted
i don't know if i'm
i don't know if i'm willing to lay my
oh what we can do here on this show and
we could probably boost these odds up to
somewhere where we've never boosted odds
up to before
but
i'm cool where i'm from we like to say
i'm cool
we don't like to do we don't like
something i'm cool i am cool connor i'm
cool after ryan taneo but we can talk cd
we can talk cd cd cd and the cowboys
face in washington uh i heard that
they're bringing their own benches to
washington to be more comfortable in
washington it's cold out there so uh
i like cd also we know what that can do
with his weapons dak and his weapons
last week you know he
he was trying to find cd a lot uh so i
like cds in that plus 115 uh connor
which way are you leaning yeah i like it
as well double digit targets for cd lamb
last week let's keep that moving
especially when he's comfortable in the
slot against a washington defense that's
banged up up front the secondary is just
not very good right now and i don't hate
washington in that game i just think
their defense is going to have a lot of
problems so i love the cdlam pick ryan
tannehill one i know i'm kind of being a
hater here but greg i'm cool on the ryan
tannehill pick where's the comment
section going on this one
cool it's cool cool
my boy connor uh let me hop into that
let me hop into the the comments let me
see what they talking about let me see
what they talking about uh oh jj snell
says neither uh
i got
jersey or bust
2021 says cd over tannehill for show
shout out to you maxwell rexell is in
the comments saying my wife got three
different sauces on my tie-dye need a
new one please maybe we'll give you a
new tie-dye max rexella go garden says
cd's going for 100 plus 100 yards plus
two tds uh it appears i'm just going to
make a decision here connor the rap the
cowboys legend
cd lam is moving on to the next round
yeah it's a wrap a pretty easy round one
i promise you round two and three don't
think they're going to be that easy easy
to decide because our next pitch comes
from the squad rod veteran
w trammel what do you got for us this
week w trammell
what's up vr nation this is lucy she
told us if we gave her some waffles for
breakfast she'd give us a lock
what do you want lucy
oh
who is it
tyree kill rocketing
lucy going with tyreek hill taking her
time making sure she got the right
waffles i've never seen a dog be that
patient around good food in my life i
like to pick here right but it's minus
money we got two wide receivers on the
board right now we know cd you can boost
that through the roof tyra kill i think
you could do some damage as well this is
a much more juicy matchup right here
greg
yes yes real juicy match up what i need
you guys to do is get in the comments
and let me know which
way we should ride should we ride with
tyree kill should we ride with cd lam
connor let me jump in here you saw how
lucy you saw how lucy
scanned
she scanned the waffle she scanned the
bucket she observed the waffles she
observed the buckets and then she went
to go pick which one uh pick the waffle
that she picked and it landed on my guy
tyree kill i said that because i think
patrick mahomes is going to do the same
thing he's going to scan the field he's
going to observe the field and then he's
going to pick apart this raiders defense
with that being said i love this the the
i love the tyree kill play love it you
guys know what we can do here is minus
135 you know what we can do conor which
way are you in yeah lucy working off
that first read and going to number two
and that was tyreek hill
i like the pick a lot i think tyrek's in
for a big day i think the chief's
offense is in for a big day and i know
the raiders play him tough don't get me
wrong but that doesn't mean you could
slow they're rolling right now greg
they're back on track the winning vibes
are back the offense is back and we know
tyra he likes them in bunches i'm
feeling this pick and you know as much
as i love cd lamb the cowboys are
healthy now gallop's back they're
spreading the ball around a little bit
when everybody's back on the field
especially amari cooper
so let's rely on the people to decide
round two of the squad ride show which
direction are they going in greg
connor i'm in the comments i am in the
comments uh here we go i see e-buggers
e-buggers one got a cd gift for us shout
out to you e buggers one you are walking
away with the hoodie elliot bowen says
elliott bowen 13 says prayers up for the
raiders secondary absolutely that's what
i'm saying let's send prayers now it is
sunday let's send prayers for that
raiders defense because patrick mahomes
tyreke hill is going to carve them up
and i'm calling it conor i'm i'm calling
it rap putting my foot down and calling
it the waffle legend
tyree kill
lucy and w travel is moving on to the
next round lucy with the big pick the
big crown in the second round but we got
one more gotta defeat the final
contender to take home the jersey the
title of squad ride get your pick
boosted on draftkings winner take all
final round
matt o'neal and jay i heard he's got
something crazy planned right here let's
see what it is
oh
yeah it's the macho me and randy savage
coming at you with the cream of the crop
top
lock pick of the week brother oh
yeah
it's a cordell patterson touchdown lock
it in boys
oh yeah brother corduro patterson coming
on the board at minus 1 30. oh yeah
against tyreek hill waffle legend macho
man legend
this is just like last round two fantasy
stars right here cp even saving teams
myself included is this enough to knock
off w trammell here greg
this one's tough connor this one is
tough uh we got cordo patterson who's
been
killing in fantasy this year breakout
season this year running back wide
receiver wide receiver running back
uh
then we also got tyrique i mentioned
what i mentioned what patrick holmes is
going to do to that raiders defense so
this one is tough conor i i really don't
know which way to go i'll be honest
which way are you leaning and then after
after you go i'm going with the people
yeah we're going to need them here
there's no doubt about that what i'll
say is
i like tyreek's match-up that's what it
comes down to me for me when you look at
cp
you know he's going against a defense
that has held running backs in check
from a fantasy perspective from a
scoring perspective now i know he does
it all he can play receiver he catches
out of the backfield
but man i feel good about tyrique
against that raider secondary i know the
comments were jumping off about that the
odds are almost even
i'm gonna roll with tyrique here greg
but let's let the comments in the br
betting section decide with a squad ride
leader for this week
connor
i'm in the hand there it is for the new
people to the show this is the handy
dandy ipad this is how you get your
hoodies
my boy albert15 said hi give it to my
boy w trammell shout out to you albert
i'm thinking about giving it to my boy w
tremble love the tyree kill play a z
jeff says hill greater than patterson
with the flex sign shout out to you ag
jeff you are walking away with the
hoodie uh i got danny rodriguez hey
danny rodriguez says see pat
connor danny rodriguez what's up right
uh
definitely is a toss-up
definitely is a toss-up i got simon
houston i think it was simon houston no
simon hudson sorry nope tyreke all day
connor i am going to call it right there
i'm going to call it right there we are
riding with the waffle legend we are
riding with tyreke hill we are riding
with lucy and most importantly let's
just let's just call my guy w trammell a
squad ride hall of famer he deserves
gold he deserves to be hung in the
raptors we're from now on we're calling
him we're referring to him as the hall
of famer has the hall of famer my guy w
trammell uh
yeah we're riding with we're watching
with tyree kill let me show you guys
this graphic so i can show you guys what
we can do here on the squad ride you
guys see the graphic it says tyree hill
minus 135 poof
there it is
there it is that's the magic that i've
been talking about thanks to our friends
at draftkings we're going to boost that
from minus 135 to plus 135 check out br
betting socials for a link to the odds
wolves send us your screenshots of your
bets send us your videos
and your celebrations but most
importantly connor we want winners and
winners only please a beautiful sight to
see all the way up flipped it upside
down plus 135 tyree kill to get in the
end zone
you guys know what to do by now we're
not done though we got more locks greg's
got more hoodies and one more nfl jersey
to give away so you know if you stick
around you usually make out pretty well
all right community comment contest time
we're talking nfl mvp race action right
now we asked you you had to put a
hundred dollars on someone to win the
mvp right now who would it be now there
is a runaway favorite at the top a guy
that you all know pretty well and tom
brady then a pretty big drop off to
aaron rodgers kyla murray another big
drop off to dak prescott patrick mahomes
matthew stafford and the only running
back on the board in jt jonathan taylor
so
right now while this looks like a
runaway it's all still plus money
there's a little room for this race to
tighten up we picked our favorite two
comments because we want to know what
you think greg what did we get this week
from the comment section on the mvp race
got you carter i need everybody to get
in the comments and tell me which of
these is the better take i'm giving away
a hoodie to whoever you guys choose
let's take a look at the first comment
from
the go
tv there won't be any bias here right
conor there won't be any bites the gold
tv says brady is the only 44 year old on
pace
for 5 300 yards and 48 touchdowns with
the 9-3 team about to win the division
for the first time in 14 years
but y'all haters haters and
but y'all are haters and trying to give
the award to somebody else whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa the goat tb
let's let's take a step back here we are
not haters here on the squad ride we
show love and an abundance of love here
on the squad ride
i actually like tom brady to win the mvp
if everything that's happened in the
season continues to happen nobody i mean
he doesn't get injured i see him
clearly walking away with the mvp trophy
connor are you a hater bro no i'm not a
tom brady hater especially since he left
new england that's made life
a little bit easier here being up in the
northeast but i mean for real no haters
no hating here and it's look at the
stats the numbers don't lie no they're
not drinking any haterade on this set
i'll tell you that right now now i'm
looking at the goat tv account i'm
wondering if tom brady is on his k.d
tray burner flow here uh this is a
little suspect but
listen he's the favorite at the top of
the board for a reason if he keeps his
foot on the gate beyond cruise control
he's gonna win this thing so
i'm not hating at all i'm sure the
comments agree that this is tom brady's
award to lose right greg
yes yes let me let me get into the
comments connor uh there's no hating on
this side uh let me see if they're
hating in the comments
i don't see any hate in the comments
brbedding is in the comments shout out
to you
danny rodriguez says he deserves it uh i
got biggie a biggs with the tom brady
gift of him uh smiling to the side shout
out to you big a biggs i also got lock
it up lock it up to saying aaron rodgers
maybe ooh
i mean you got a gift with aaron rodgers
going
so i like that now let's discuss the
next comment
connor from my guy
bry
guy
bry guy says jonathan taylor is sitting
at
1 348 yards and 16 touchdowns with four
games to go i think he can go off down
the stretch and get the coach to the
playoffs
plus 1600 ain't a bad bet at all
now i i i like the wishful thinking
connor i i like the wishful thinking but
my man's like he's gonna have to go
bunkers he's gonna have to go
crazy he's gonna have to do some
something that we've probably never
seen before in order for him to just
take this mvp trophy away from tom brady
he's sitting at plus 1600 for a reason
i'm not hating i'm not hating i'm just
saying my guy's gonna go he's gonna have
to go out there and put on an absolute
show to steal this from tom brady what's
your thoughts the take is right right
brian is he's right over there that look
at the numbers look at what jt has done
but greg they didn't give derek henry
any love when he was doing this or even
doing this at a higher level why are
they going to change now it shows that
the award is broken it's a broken system
so the plus 1600 to me is a bit of a
sucker bet you look at it and go
jonathan taylor should be the mvp or a
top mvp candidate the odds are plus 1600
maybe i can make a quick buck here but
it's not your fault jonathan taylor it's
not your fault the fans that think he
should win it's that the voting system
for the award is broken just like the
heisman it's a award that generally goes
to quarterbacks or guys that are the
face of that franchise and this award
has not been won by a running back since
2012 with adrian peterson when he was
the biggest you know freak in the league
in terms of what he can do production
wise so
it's tough it's just it's not realistic
i hate to be the bad guy there it's just
and at the comments right but the mvp
has become most valuable quarterback not
most valuable football player that's the
issue
i mean connor you have a fair fair point
and you have the statistics to back it
up you brought on some statistics for
the mvp race man i love it uh here we go
we got d-boy 22 in the comments says if
derek can hey connor he's he's preaching
he's preaching what you preach he says
if derek henry it's right there if derek
henry didn't get
then get it at 2k yards no way jt even
does this shout out to you d boy22 you
are walking away with the hoodie uh
uh i got i want to win you guys see him
i dm'd you haven't heard back we will
get back to you brother we will get back
to you go white sox you see it right
there jt let's get it
rocking with jt shout out to you
um
look at go white sox is in the comments
again elliot bowen says tj tj watt
deserves some mvp votes hey shout out to
everybody that i mentioned you guys are
walking away with a hoodie uh bry guy
i'm gonna go with bride guy here
i'm gonna go with brian guy here connor
johnson i'm gonna give bry guy
i'm gonna send bry guy a hoodie uh
bright guy you are the winner of the
comments contest
shout out to you brother all right greg
before we get to our boldest bets let's
talk a little player props from this
weekend's slate it's a good slate we got
some guys getting healthy at the right
time of the year
so you need a little help from the squad
you know what to do you decide if it's a
lock or a drop and we'll kick things off
first here greg tell them what we got
that's right everybody i need you to get
in the comments and tell me if these
props are a lock
or if we need to drop them e immediately
i'm giving away hoodies to whoever can
help us out all right let's check out
the prop there it is my man alvin kamara
over or under 69 and a half rushing
yards this is kamehameha first game back
since week nine
my man mark ingram is out today connor
which will give camara the workload do
you like the over or do you like the
under here i love the over the jets run
defenses doesn't really exist it's not
real it's not a thing they can't stop
anyone on the ground and taysom hill
will eat some of those yards greg
because he can't throw quite frankly and
he won't need to today he could just run
on the jets so i think that's the one
concern that you have here is that
taysom starts to get a lot of those
carries or you know the saints want to
monitor camaro but i'll say this camaro
almost played 10 days ago it came down
to a game time decision so now he's had
10 more days he should be 100 healthy
ready to go ready to be that workhorse
kind of back against a great match-up
for him
you know me greg i don't like rushing
total overs i like this one a lot
connor likes it hey
the the the saints are facing connor's
team connor is there's no
telling you guys
that uh camaro is gonna rush for over 69
and a half against his own team so that
should tell you guys something because
i'm also going to piggyback with you
connor i think camara is going to go
over here uh he's he's going to be the
he's going to be the he's going to be
the guy today he's going to be the guy
no mark ingram they can't really throw
the ball you mentioned it they're going
to have to run it
one run one run can pop this so uh i'm
rocking with the over i'm rocking with
the over let's move on to the next prop
actually before i do that
you know what i gotta do connor
it's it's christmas season i gotta give
away sir i got to give away some hoodies
uh let me give away one
i got hayden hayden bowers rock oh i
think i gave you a hoodie already
uh
hayden bowers rock says
a minimum of 150 yards also tanahan
tannehill russian td bookit shout out to
you uh w trammell is in the comments
he's also he's on the show he's also in
the comments there he is right there
says over over over shout out to you
let's move on connor let's move on
all right the next prop we're talking
tyler murray
my man kyler murray two throw over or
under
263 and a half passing yards had four
total touchdowns last week rushed into
threw for two
threw for 123 yards last week connor
last time the cardinals played the rams
in week four
murray had the best game of his career
so
talk to me connor do you like this do
you like the over do you like the
actually i'll go first let me jump in
because i i just want to
he had
123 last week connor
now we're sitting at 263 against this
rams defense i i just don't know if
tyler murray's fully healthy i don't
know if he's fully healthy i mean i know
he went for four touchdowns he ran for
two but throwing the ball out like 263
that's just a lot for me after just
throwing for 123. what's your take
connor greg they asked him to throw 15
times last game so you have to be
concerned at the fact that it's not that
kyle murray is not good it's not that
kyle murray won't be a stud this week
it's not any hate on the cardinals it's
the fact that
they don't need him to come out and do
this they don't need him to come out and
try to throw for 300 plus yards every
single week because what he can do with
his legs they have james connor in the
backfield they're getting chase edmonds
back who's their pass catching running
back
i look at this game and go man maybe
some people think shootout against the
rams it's possible but at the end of the
day i it's not that he's not talented
enough to do this or good enough right
now it's that the opportunity it's hard
to believe it's there so these are
traditionally ones that i stay away from
because the unpredictable nature of this
division match-up but if i had to go i
would stay away from the over i would
hit the under on this one
conor's hidden me under i'm hitting the
under i'm back into the handy danny
seeing what they are hitting i got
jesse24 says under shout out to you
jesse24 you are walking away with the
hoodie lock it up says 63 is a lot i
agree there it is lock it up is right
there 263 is a lot yes i agree lock it
up 263 is a lot jay lawson is telling us
to bless up bless up to you too my
brother uh here we go i love imp and
does 13. murray is getting the under due
to james connor's spotlight game shout
out to everybody that i just mentioned
seems like they're riding with us connor
shout out to everybody that just met you
all are walking away with
a hoodie all right may the betting prop
gods being everyone's favor we are not
out of here just yet we gotta do our
boldest bets of the week greg and i have
been having some fun with this one
greg what do we need from the one last
question from the people here
hey what i need you guys to do is get in
the comments and ride connor's parlay
because it hit last week and i like it
this week again connor
matter of fact tell the people what your
parlay is right now brother let's get
straight to it yeah i hit a long slump
there greg but we're back we're hot
we're starting a new streak here if it's
not broken don't fix it another underdog
parlay plus 395 ravens underdogs going
to cleveland against those browns okay
yeah let's jump on the ravens here money
line
falcons upsetting the reeling panthers
right now we talked about corduro
patterson earlier in this show
here it is greg two teams two upset wins
worked last week let's run it back where
are you going this week
connor i just want to admire your parlay
bro i love you that you're doing these
underdogs parlays i rode your one last
week and i'm riding this one this week
with that being said we've been talking
about tyreek hill he's actually our
squad right leader let's pull up the
graphics so i can show the people there
it is right there the graphic is right
there i'm going with tyree kill to score
two or more
touchdowns against that raiders defense
this is solely because they are playing
the raiders patrick mahomes had a great
game the first week they played the
first time they played the raiders
if it ain't broke connor don't fix it
you don't think he's going to double
back and have a good game this week i
don't know if you do but i do and with
that being said his favorite target his
favorites one of his favorite targets he
likes travis kelsey too but one of his
favorite targets is tyree kiel
and tyree kill likes to score touchdowns
in bunches so therefore i'm rocking with
tyree kill two touchdowns or more let's
go
patrick holmes let's go tyree kill we
are riding i love this greg he did it
against the raiders last time two
touchdowns why not do it again they
don't have an answer for him in their
secondary right now so i like where your
head is at there plus 400 let's make
some money today let's have some fun
jump on the boldest bets before we leave
you we need two things we need one the
comments got to let us know are they
going with the underdog parlay are they
going with tyrique two touchdowns y'all
should at least be going with tyrique
one touchdown that's the squad ride
bumped up today why not make it two
and you have one more nfl jersey to give
away before we get out of here
yes sir i am in the comments right now
oh my boy matt dodger is in the comments
matt dodger
matt dodger says let's go greg shout out
to you matt dodger you are walking away
with the jersey matt dodger also uh-oh
matt dodger also uh he's he commented
earlier i saw what he said earlier he he
mentioned he mentioned tom brady winning
mvp love that take matt dodger you were
walking away with the jersey i saw your
comment earlier i'm back into the
comments though i got a a bowliner
connor street coming to an end and
you're walking away with a hoodie big
mike 13 riding with connor got to love
them underdogs i'm riding with connor
too i am riding with connor too love
those underdogs there it is uh big mike
13 you are also welcome uh oh hold on g
quinn right above him
oh i like that plus money i like that
i'm going to ride it with you connor
look you're you're just getting fans you
got something you're getting fans all in
the comments section they love you bro i
love your parlay too actually send that
to me connor after the show send me your
parlay i'm putting it on the br bender
story how about that let's do it let's
do it let's do it i'm not letting you
get out of here without giving away that
jersey
the jersey mad dodger matt dodd is
welcome dodger
he mentioned he mentioned tom brady
winning mvp he also mentioned the two
touchdowns for uh tyree kill matt dodger
you are walking away with that jersey
all right you heard it everyone good
luck with your wagers today congrats to
all our hoodie and jersey winners if you
want vr betting is going to dm you in
the next 24 hours thanks to everyone
that commented thanks to our lock
legends bauer sock numero the goat w
trammell matt o'neal aka macho man randy
savage over there enjoy the games today
everybody drop your real time takes in
the sports betting community stream in
that bleacher report app follow greg on
those ig stories all day there's rumors
i'm gonna jump in there as well and give
that parlay out let's have some fun
alongside the man greg ivory i'm connor
rogers see y'all next time next time
same time
same place
[Music]
you